Hey David, is it now time for Bernie or Warren
to drop out because Joe Biden is still in
the lead and we as progressives need to take
him out.
So listen, I've answered this a couple of
times before and it's been a few months so
I'm glad to address it again because we're
further into the democratic primary at this
point.
What exactly would be the point of Bernie
or Warren dropping out as the question is
asked here, the point would be we don't want
Biden to win cause he's not a progressive.
Bernie and Warren are the two Progressive's
with the best shot.
If one drops out, it helps the other.
It takes out Biden and then we laugh all the
way to the bank.
Okay.
The problem with this is the math of it and
the math of it is I reviewed earlier today,
still doesn't really favor this strategy.
You know, I got a, I did a live stream, uh,
over the weekend on Twitch and I got a phone
call from someone who said, Hey David, you
know, I want, I think it was Bernie to win
or something like that.
I want Bernie to win, but if Bernie doesn't
win Iowa, should I maybe look at switching
my vote when I vote in New York state, the
caller was in New York state voter and I said,
guys, you're getting way ahead of yourselves
here.
You don't need to do anything like that.
Nothing is going to be, there's one way in
which those first four primaries, Iowa and
New Hampshire, Nevada and South Carolina will
really sort of quote, decide the winner, which
is if one person sweeps all of them and does
it really handily like with overwhelming numbers,
which is not likely to happen at this point.
Okay.
The most likely scenario is that no matter
what happens in those first four primaries,
it's still going to be a fight into March
3rd I think March 3rd is super.
Tuesday, there's like 14 primaries on March
3rd maybe super Tuesday is actually a different
date, but there's a huge chunk of votes that
are going to be coming after those four primaries.
Okay.
Any, anyone will almost likely, uh, be able
to win after those first four support.
Who you like?
If it's Bernie or Warren, that's totally fine
because here's the math about Bernie and Warren.
Okay.
Uh, Warren supporters have Bernie as their
second choice, but only by three points over
Biden.
Okay.
Meaning that for every hundred, I believe
I'm going by the numbers.
I recall for every hundred Warren supporters
that changed their minds.
Or if Warren bails go to their second choice
candidate for every hundred, I think 28 go
to Bernie and 25 go to Biden.
Okay.
That's not enough for Bernie to close the
gap.
If Warren quits.
All right, now let's look at the other option.
Bernie quits Bernie supporters.
Now, according to the latest morning consult
poll, Bernie supporters have Biden as their
top choice by two points over Warren, I think
it's like 28 to 26 so if Bernie quits for
every hundred of his supporters that go to
their second choice, Biden builds a lead over
Elizabeth Warren.
Okay?
If either drops out, they help each other
and Biden roughly equally so the math doesn't
support the strategy of Bernie quitting to
help Warren or Warren quitting to help Bernie.
Now you could say, well, those might be the
second choices as of now, but if one quits
and endorses the other, then it'll shift those
numbers.
It may shift the numbers to some degree, but
we're just talking about the primaries here
and it, it, I, I, my prediction is it would
not shift it as much as you imagined.
So let's just all go out.
If you're an Iowa voter, you're going to get
the first crack at it.
Go out and vote, whoever you actually support.
If you're a New Hampshire voter and Iowa doesn't
go the way you want, go out and vote for whoever
you actually support in New Hampshire.
If one person wins Iowa and another one's
new who wins New Hampshire and then it's time
for Nevada, I believe is the third primary.
Go out and vote for whoever you like in Nevada.
This is going to sort itself out.
There is so much time for consolidation in
the Bernie Warren, uh, supporter groups that
these are not the things we should be to the,
the candidates who are in the top three should
not drop out.
There's a whole bunch of people at the bottom
that need to go because they've got no shot
and they're just a distraction on the stage,
but it is not time for Bernie to drop out.
It is not a time for Warren to drop out.
Why would someone in the top three who is
right in there within a few points of being
in the lead of this thing drop out at this
point in time?
My suggestion is that we stopped talking about
that and focus on the important things like
substantive debates, figuring out exactly
how each person will pay for their healthcare
plan and clearing the stage of some of the
hangers on that have no chance whatsoever
of winning and are contributing nothing other
than giving the people who have a shot time
to sip water as they wait for the next question
to come to them.
You disagree with me, let me know.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Two ways to get the bonus show,
become a member@joinpacmandotcomorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David [inaudible], the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.